-Here to perform "Dying Breed"
from their number-1 album,
"Imploding the Mirage,"
from the Top of the Rock,
give it up for The Killers!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ There's gonna be opposition ♪
♪ Ain't no way around it ♪
♪ But if you're looking for
strong and steady ♪
♪ Well, baby, you found it ♪
♪ We'll weather
the coldest night ♪
♪ Baby, we're a dying breed ♪
♪ When everyone's compromising ♪
♪ I'll be your diehard ♪
♪ I'll be there when
water's rising ♪
♪ I'll be your lifeguard ♪
♪ We're cut from
a stained-glass mountain ♪
♪ Baby, we're a dying breed ♪
Hey!
♪ Na-na-na-na, na-na ♪
♪ When facing the wind
got wicked ♪
♪ We rallied and raised up ♪
-♪ Raised up ♪
-♪ Now if
she comes back kicking ♪
♪ We'll know what
we're made of ♪
-♪ Raised up ♪
-♪ There's gonna be opposition ♪
♪ But we've got
everything we need ♪
-♪ Raised up ♪
-♪ Ooh, baby,
we're a dying breed ♪
-Hey!
1, 2, 3!
♪ From the coveted touch
of a girl in love ♪
♪ I was lifted by the sound of
a spirit in need ♪
♪ Baby, we're a dying breed ♪
♪ Na-na-na-na, na-na ♪
♪ I don't know what
you want from me ♪
♪ Sometimes, I don't know
what to do ♪
♪ It's like I'm screaming
in a dream ♪
♪ It's like
I can't get through ♪
♪ What if we're
not prepared for this? ♪
♪ What if we just can't
find the trail? ♪
♪ Then I remember
the promise I made ♪
♪ And the way that I fell ♪
♪ For the coveted touch of
a girl in love ♪
♪ I was taken by the sound
of a spirit in need ♪
♪ Baby, we're a dying breed ♪
♪ We've got everything we need ♪
♪♪
♪ Baby, we're a dying breed ♪
♪ We've got everything we need ♪
♪ Na-na-na-na, na-na ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]